we got a series here called rebuilding
America and we are highlighting efforts
in that series to build a better world
that includes people trying to build a
better home for themselves Americans are
expected believe it or not to spend a
record 485 billion dollars on home
repairs and remodeling in 2023 and that
number includes do-it-yourself projects
of those folks 90 of them nine out of
ten watch videos on social media to try
to figure out how to do the work but in
my case none of that the answer to all
Home Improvement problems in my house
from the gunk under the sink to the chip
cabinets in the kitchen my solution has
been ignore it ignore it ignore it that
has changed however thanks to what I
learned from a DIY star of social media
hi I'm Bob Vila welcome home again if
you're like me you've spent countless
hours watching other people renovate
their homes on television look at you
crown molding experts and if you've been
inspired to rehab your own home as
Millions have you probably know that
hiring a professional contractor isn't
always necessary I am going to save you
a bunch of time on your next tiling
project not when social media is now
packed with tutorials that make even
major home renovations look easy for a
do-it-yourselfer you can just stand it
up and cut it in a regular 45 degree
angle but over at real life renovation
on Instagram and Tick Tock a
self-described dummy named Alex
d'alessio has a different approach did
you really just break the drain he's
built an audience of hundreds of
thousands of followers around a major
dose of DIY reality
this is not always easy
and you will screw it up sometimes how's
the drawer hanging going uh it is going
below par which is on par with how it
goes for me okay and sure enough when I
stopped by recently to see Alex at work
I have no idea what to call this thing a
cabinet hardware jig maybe mistakes were
made
uh that did not work out but for a
lifelong DIY skeptic like me Alex's
message is inspiring maybe I can take on
a project or two here's just how easy it
is to change the outdated light fixture
in your home that you've been putting
off forever for Alex the proof is
everywhere inside the townhouse he and
his wife Kylie bought in Baltimore in
2020 his first project an attempt to
save a few bucks on a table Kylie was
like we need to get like a 500 coffee
table we need this and this I was like
let's spend the same amount of money
half the money on the tools in the wood
if I can't build it I'll let you get
whatever coffee table you want if you
don't like it and I let it rip he
learned everything he needed from what
he calls YouTube University what's the
power of Google YouTube and some lessons
learned along the way and he's since
done work on the laundry room the
basement a home bar the primary bathroom
and now his bedroom here's how my
mother-in-law and I installed faux brick
in my bedroom made it look real and how
you you can too how much money would you
have spent on professionals or
store-bought stuff if you just did it
the normal way I would say if all
together probably at least 80 90 and how
much did it actually cost you maybe 10
with the tools materials all that that's
a pretty good advertisement for this way
of living yeah what's going on with you
man thank you for coming to me though
DIY renovation still sounded like a
pretty good recipe for messing up my
house especially if Alex no offense was
the one doing the work
after all he was until recently a guy
with a master's degree in a corporate
job who had never even run a power tool
now welcome back to day 39 to finish my
basement by myself he is a full-time
social media star but that doesn't
exactly make him a skilled Tradesman and
his assistant not an apprentice
Carpenter but his mother-in-law Sherry
who herself had doubts about Alex
working as his own handyman part of me
you know reacted like any normal parent
would like oh my God you're gonna throw
away six years of school and I gave him
six months yeah he said by March of 2021
if you don't have something lined up or
if it's not getting better then you're
going back to work but he has lined up
paid sponsors saying he now makes double
what he was earning at his old corporate
job the wear and tear is considerable so
maybe I thought we'll take on a couple
small jobs around the house the chip
paying on my kitchen cabinets and the
mold colony in the caulk under my
kitchen sink we can definitely get this
right so now we need a stirring stick
almost right away we ran into some
issues I have to like take out
Chopsticks bro yeah that'll work first
with the paint yep we're gonna smooth
all that out which look not exactly
great after our first coat I thought
this was going to cut out a lot easier
and then at the sink here we go I got
some slice inhabitant now oh nasty we
had a heck of a Time removing all the
mystery goo it's like actually oozing oh
it's a juicy monster back there but in
between the curse words
Dynasty and a particularly awful smell
you saw why I took a step back guys
something remarkable happened
on caulk out of its tube no matter what
we tried now we're going in and just
when we were about to give up
Joe on camera one with a suggestion why
don't you YouTube it so in the end Alex
got help the very same way he gives it
there's no way that you could ever get
that to come out
through the wonders of the internet
[Music]
hey look at that
look at that and that's what's so great
about this era you didn't have to have a
parent teach you this I literally we
literally just learned it together we
didn't know if it was going to work and
here we are this is extremely DIY it was
wasn't he but it got the job
and no the kitchen wasn't Flawless but
it was definitely better and in the
world of DIY I've learned better is
absolutely perfect you screw up a lot
don't you
yes and I let hundreds of thousands of
people know it and I think that's what
we all do it but that's the real life in
real life renovation 100 and that's why
I started it
thank you Alex I feel converted I loved
hanging out with him I loved his whole
family real life renovation is a really
useful site and you can do this people
the amount of money he said that he
saved spending around 10 saving around
80 or 90 yeah
a lot of savings but the risk is also
High I have to I have some chips on my
cabinet too and I I'm too afraid to mess
it up one the line is no major Plumbing
or electricity people yeah you're my
words